[Musique]
faut être violent contre la compétition
il faut être violent contre la violence
de même que la seule guerre bonne new
deal à des pierres c'est la guerre
contre la misère est bien la seule
violence est la violence contre la
violence
car au fond être compétitif ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire vouloir passer devant
un autre et on apprend que ça à l'école
dans aviator
non c'est pas ça on apprenait autrefois
et quels sont les grands personnages qui
ont fait avancer la science
qu'en faire avancer la pensée humaine il
n'était pas compétitif et sunstein était
compétitif absolument pas il se battait
contre personne il n'avait pas envie
d'arriver le premier il avait envie de
comprendre les choses qu'ils
n'arrivaient pas à comprendre est que
les autres croyaient avoir compris mais
il avait bien tort vient lui se battait
contre lui-même
la compétition mais faut il réfléchir un
peu chaque fois que l'on accepte la
compétition on accepte maîtriser
quelqu'un de le détruire et on est en
train de se détruire soi même puisque un
beau jour on perdra c'est pas sérieux ni
pour un état ni pour une collectivité
quelconque ni pour un individu être
compétitif ça ne peut pas être le bon
moteur il ya d'autres moteurs dans la
vie et malheureusement on nous raconte
aussi que la sélection naturelle veut
que les meilleurs gagnent c'est faux
s'est jamais le meilleur qui gagne on
gagne pas simplement il faut survivre il
faut avancer il faut être meilleur que
soi même c'est complètement différent
mais quand est-ce qu'on l'aura compris
je crois que actuellement le drame de
notre de la terre entière sait que la
société qui domine un autre a pris comme
botteur la compétition mais il faut y
réfléchir c'est forcément un poison mais
je vais me faire l'avocat du diable
est ce que la rentabilité n'est quand
même pas obligatoire pour faire vivre
les milliards d'hommes qui sont sur
cette planète et qui vont doubler d'ici
combien de temps ils vont doubler d'ici
80 ans oui on sera 10 milliards mais si
on essaie d'organiser la terre en
fonction de la rentabilité
on est fichu car en fait les activités
les plus nécessaire à l'homme ce sont
celles qui sont pas rentables
ce n'est pas rentable de guérir un
vieillard ce n'est pas rentable de
d'éduquer quelqu'un dès qu'on met le
concept de rentabilité là dedans on
aboutit à la barbarie et au fond c'est
parce qu'on a parlé de rentabilité à
propos du sens qu'on a obtenu ce que
vous savez le fameux scandale du sang il
faut absolument sortir rue l'essentiel
des activités humaines
de ce domaine où l'économie règne à la
rentabilité règne non ce qui est
important dans la vie c'est ce qui n'est
pas rentable
dites moi vous devez être horriblement
pessimiste plus que nous qui voyait la
réalité vous voyez la réalité plus vite
mieux que nous non je suis pas
pessimiste est pessimiste ça voudrait
dire que c'est foutu ça peut l'être
il est possible que ce soit mais ça
dépend encore de nous je pense qu'il
n'est pas tout à fait trop tard mais il
faut complètement changer nos objectifs
l'objectif de compétition l'objectif de
rentabilité
ça c'est la catastrophe par contre vivre
vivre vivre c'est ça qu'ils font ces
gens et c'est ça que veulent les enfants
ça que veulent les jeunes quand on leur
a parlé diplôme de type est tout le
reste
ou faut il s'en foutait ce qu'ils
veulent c'est avoir une vie qui s'ouvre
c'est possible au contraire ils seront à
la chance au fond que le monde de demain
soit nécessairement différent du monde
d'aujourd'hui
qu'on le veuille ou pas il sera
différent alors où on le subit ou le
dirige
ainsi toutes les intelligences qui
gouvernent était comme jour professeur
jacquard notre devoir
[Musique]